[Music]
welcome to another episode of what's in
the box
I'm more Mindy today we're gonna look at
these three boxes and what's inside and
I here pray tell there might be another
box but we can't get to the fourth till
get through the first through you ready
sounds like a liftoff no blades
necessary this week kids put your knives
away we don't need them all we have to
do is this count of three three one two
why did you start it at three yeah yeah
oh he's down isn't it it was like a
scene from lethal weapon we go on three
three yelling one two and three one two
three we got a pyro
yes winner winner whoa
this is pretty impressive you know I'll
let you lift this buddy good Oh people
more yeah it's the Merc with the mouth
all right so I'm sensing a theme Marvel
heroes writ large in such a way that if
you put them on display in your home
you'll never get laid again these are
impressive man let's be honest this
looks as impressive as like a votive
statue in a Catholic Church
I see there's a little piece here I'm
not feeling that it lights up inside you
think his head comes off I hope just
gently lift okay my wire please don't
break it lift straight up and don't let
it touch oh look so this one oh oh so
you could be Tony Stark or you could be
iron yes choose this mask do you think
like an armor Downey jr. owned this he
would be like look I prefer my face but
everyone else wants that mark 42
autonomous prehensile propulsion suit
test initialize sequence Jarvis drop my
needle here we go I'm pressing the light
okay on iron
oh it's his chest his eyes his hands I
know that on is a night light at night
when you're scared you have to get up go
to the bathroom and whatnot always look
at that and be more scared by the notion
that it somehow gives you comfort based
on a scene from Iron Man 3 so when they
throw Tony's mansion into the ocean and
then he pops up later on
do you like this Ironman suit design
I'll turn I wouldn't say it's much no I
liked it I liked the Allred I like that
bro you don't like when it has like
highlights and the gold and stuff I'm
not a big fan of the coal that I could
already
I believe he's always Gold's always
involved a little bit yes you think
they've got so much gold yeah tube is
too much flare and in terms of speaking
like that movie that everybody loves if
you want me to wear 37 pieces of flair
like you're a pretty boy over there
Brian why don't you just make the
minimum 37 pieces of flair yeah might
put some racing stripes here maybe some
flames it's weird man you buy a statue
for like 450 bucks like kids it comes
with action rebar all right this is
Deadpool cue the music
that [ __ ] head is amazing look at the
detail Oh Casper and look at this gun
boy you look at the gun boy those done
actually Cox detail men armed with five
weapons katanas on his back knife on the
lag handgun a small assault rifle man
it's only twelve hundred and fifty of
them made in the world
it weighs ten pounds is are true yeah
you get a good workout go yeah baby
curls just mulch you can go each morning
you could wake up and put a different
head on yeah two different looks fun
basically he's kind of like the Jack
Skellington of the Marvel Universe man
he's got those expressions expression
your eyes
what's this there's white beans in there
what's this oh my god feel faster than
[ __ ]
let's go kidnap mr. Santa Claus hey look
at this this is a lifetime commitment
you're either massively into Marvel or
you're a Norse mythological fan or
that's your religion you're like I pray
to Odin of it
I'm Odin king of Ascot protector of the
nine realms inspired by the designs of
Marvel artists Olivier Koeppel Destin
Livi oohs that's Olivia's statue leave
it all it looks like it belongs in
Bolivia's man when you're picking up
pizza he like Canaria slice hey it's
[ __ ] Thor over there look at how
massive it is look at this comes off
today's ewod Asian so is this how you
normally get more or less it's a good
luck his suit is made of cloth does it
look like homeboy a movie no oh yeah oh
my god that ain't names were that's Jay
Leno look at that chin massive that is
man if Jay Leno was the god of thunder
you might be fourth as good this might
be for those good all these come from
the good folks at Sideshow Collectibles
and come on look at this craftsman and
crafts woman ship call it whatever you
want
it's almost witchcraft they're so
goddamn [ __ ] beautiful I used to have
these back when I was single and stuff
I'm certainly not saying my wife got rid
of them by yes yeah no I'm just kidding
I started Hawking them though I started
selling them stuff those babies are
expensive man I'm all right I know I'm
pretty expensive yeah that was the baby
oh yeah question let me ask you about
sculptures cuz you're a real sculpture
or yourself I remember buying what for
my money is the first comic book store
or comic book related sculpture and it
was when graffiti designs did Randy
Bowens Sandman stitch and yes I remember
like I paid 150 bucks for some [ __ ] and
I was still living at home my parents
and my parents were like if you can
afford to buy that you could start
paying rent these things way bigger than
that like my salmon statue is this high
alright how much would you pay for [ __ ]
like this dude let's start with the Dead
Pool Premium Format sideshow collectible
well I'll call it a figure but it's you
know it's a doll right like you could do
[ __ ] with
yeah like just this well there's
articulation here crazy articulation
what would you pay for that crazy
articulation 299 keep going
399 drop it by 50 bucks 353 $14 $2.99
$349 for a [ __ ] doll I'm not saying
that's a bad thing because these guys
make great [ __ ] but you walk into the
wrong store and some kid [ __ ] picks
this up mom I want Deadpool and they're
like okay without looking at it man and
suddenly it's like 350 clans you're
gonna get a smack every parent be like
[ __ ] it
70s are back okay 350 there are kids
starving if I was a guy behind the
counter even if I didn't own the place
I'm walking by and I see this
consternation going on I would
immediately get up and advocate for this
I'm like yes it's 350 bucks believe the
articulation the gun [ __ ] yeah I was
like don't you love your kid that's what
I'd say right more than the kid your mom
must not love you che Myranda buying it
now these aren't nearly as fun because
they're not like dolls and poseable and
stuff so this is just kind of like yeah
these are statement pieces why would you
put this in your house on a mantle or
you think there'd be a man cave
you know honestly I'd be tempted to put
them in the bathroom where would you put
I was through my man cave but with all
the sculptures so then they just forget
it's like [ __ ] Raiders a lost art the
ending man it's just like a series of
[ __ ] crates and I open boxes thank
you to get out into books it'll go down
in value by five dollars aboard I take
my hat how much would you pay for this
Ironman remember how much ride two heads
are better than one man so you get a lot
of head with the Ironman statute what
would you pay for this
Iron Man mark 42 quarter scale similar
scale so this is only a quarter as big
as Robert Downey jr. if we had four of
these we would have a full Robert Downey
jr. yeah that makes sense
oh are you [ __ ] high nothing in this
world is $7.99 I know I'm telling you
I'm telling you
429 bucks what about this well now that
I know I would say 499 439 man I dare
you to give one of these to your wife as
an anniversary gift and be like this is
how I feel about you
you're my mole on you
or this is how I feel about you you
protect me like Iron Man's Marc [ __ ]
16 suit or whatever the [ __ ]
high 42 what are these things how high
they got hmm get the [ __ ] suit right
the first time that's 42 all right so
which one if I'm like I dare you give
this to you what which one is gonna be
lost offensive yes I'm wondering I think
if I put this one on this head yes then
at least it's Tony Stark I mean a Downey
jr. feel like I love you so much I gave
you a Robert energy yes I'm like look
you can look at them all time and think
there's a really cool junkie he turned
his [ __ ] around maybe my man could do it
I'm you look at that good you see iron
muse [ __ ]
nice all right Matt's one thing to
receive sculptures as a gift what you're
wonderful but you can't really play the
muck ah you know the moment you go to
play them your mom's like get off and it
cost 400 so you can't really play I
suspect good times we had inside this
box pull out mulling your your knife
Mullen - York and stab his [ __ ] box
like you were for there we go
looking at that looking at it whirring
online I was playing before and I said
and I was trying to oh we kid we got as
kids we got Lego vendors man and couple
controllers in the box to tell me that
good times are about to be ahead
all right this is a scene from Iron Man
3 I press your button there you are bro
I'm all Sirhan ah
or you can move characters it looks like
look at me way up I suddenly hear I'm
when to go look at him bro I am James
Spader man but I'm not playing James
Spader from Avengers age of Ultron I'm
playing James Spader from pretty and
pink you got a plan Fred this is when he
was all snobby about Blaine and [ __ ] oh
it's okay now you're firing at me you
actually know I'm trying to whip your
ass oh yeah that's what James Spader
does that's how he rolls
[Applause]
outside which Quicksilver are you are
you the one from the x-men movie because
if you are that's badass but if you're
one from the Avengers run Doctor Strange
dude let me see if I can get the little
[ __ ] magic in this yeah this is the
best dude Oh Iron Monger bro yes dude
your planet's [ __ ] Jeff Bridges right
now you're the dude this telecare really
tied the room together man hit you with
my magic son bang yes laid me out eating
right man nice shot magic right up your
rectum oh my god new night dude bring it
on they got no naka mere marc spector
oh here we go we're gonna check out as
guard let's do it
here's the Rainbow Bridge game well I
gotta become Hulk dent and and come on
that was worth the price of admission
alone oh [ __ ] I almost wore off the
bridge man like [ __ ] Han Solo as you
can see nothing but loads of fun for
somebody who wants to be every character
in the Marvel Universe what an amazing
game look I love the Lego games I used
to play them with my kid when she was
little and whatnot just run around
breaking stuff so this is fun and
Stanley does a voice in it as does Lou
Ferrigno I enjoyed it I'll be honest
with you I like to sculpt here a little
more I know I bitched about how
inanimate the sculpture is but I'd get
more enjoyment out of that sculpture
because I know it would irritate the
people in my life if they have to pass
that sculpture every day like what a
child he is that's a win for me so at
the end of the day we opened up the box
this week we found a bunch of Marvel
cool stuff man including sculptures and
a lego game man what do you want to see
us pull out of a box heavens just let
the screen junkies know they'll tell us
they don't hold anything back man let me
know on Twitter Facebook this address
below us and we will open up anything
anything turn around open your cheeks
watch this
spread he's used to doing that at the
border so we'll do that for you as well
man but let us know until then I've been
Kevin Smith
JC Muse and this has been what's in the
box and what's in the box this week was
was a bunch of sculptures in the video
game
[Music]